Rob it's okay you don't need to be
afraid the claymation monsters now
they're scary but they're cool when
they're animated with 2d characters cuz
you know that I said they're scary
didn't you ever sit the rankin/bass yes
and freaking rudl baby hey which is
ironic cuz you kind of look like a
puppet right now you almost kind of look
like that garbage thing from Fraggle
Rock hey pretty Dingle
- anywho very scary this is little gift
Shop of Horrors another anthology one um
which I actually like more than the
first one uh for any other reason cuz
the stop-motion creatures so now
everyone like instead that's where
they're gonna be asking for the laundry
basket back won't you mr. head again it
is very puppet wait wait now I'm The
Cheapskate let me know you're the kid
stuck in the pool on the fourth of July
is tonight better the harness
so yes uh uh as you probably know this
is you the viewer go into the shop and
stand tries to sell you this stuff and
he makes up stories about them which i
think is fine he acknowledges he's
making them up true um so it's obviously
not much about like the mystery aspect
but the stories are very very funny one
is about stanga knees hands chopped off
by the hand witch and getting those back
which in case you're just joining us
Manos the hands of faith yes um which
actually means hands the hands of fate
liable reference hold Leah Manos
reference um the event one of the things
he was gonna sell as the I of sorry
oh that was hilarious sounds great and
that's not for sale
well right I'll just need the BR two
things I saw one was there's a book on
crippled G in the waddles one which was
pretty clever and then the hand is
actually the Game of Thrones thrown up
and she sits on at the end of that you
saw about the waddles he uh what he's
super when he Stephen Hawking pink when
he's Steven Hawking
I like this was a waddles episode cuz
there's just there's okay I have no
having as models is that there's no
waddles episode
oh no waddles been taken okay he's still
just a thing you know he doesn't have a
personality living human and porcine pig
being this one he at least has a
personality so I like that but it wasn't
real is a made-up stay it's like my
refers to it's like the one time for
this speech does something at all a
dream so it's like doesn't count she
could fly in that game yeah god I was a
dream so an amazing dream but then in
the real world we'll give her a game
where like her PMS is the power so now
she's angry now she said and that's her
weapon it's it's pretty wedding I cuz
the frying pan wasn't enough that was
too dignified you would bring him yes
feel better than the freaking turnips
from Super Mario Brothers to okay and
she could fly was in that game were
vegetables so she wants to set it up she
wants the best character Mario to I me
there is like hands down
oh well now wait a second let's not
discount the fact that toad could pick
up all the coins really quick and that
Luigi actually was technically at all in
John Bottomly the most useless character
in Mario Brothers 2 was Mario he was
like totally useless nobody was ever
Mario that's true it's like why be Mario
he is the most average character so II
to me just okay so um yeah anywho uh so
the next one waddle get smart uh but
then realizes you like the friendship
with Mabel so it goes back with that and
then the last one this wonderful super
clever Harry oh my god Bela trilliant
where they actually are stop-motion and
they make a lot of great jokes about
about how expensive it is
EP the fact that a stop-motion really
doesn't exist it's all black magic which
brings me to what was said in the other
credits no that was the greatest line to
just like what I'm not some sort of
masochist
what sort of fool do you think would sit
there and animus for daisa
I like the Craig name is to say you know
it's done by socially awkward shut it
they're called animator
all the animators so two one two in this
one check out dr. walls latest book a
brief history of wink wink wink and
finally all animation is black magic is
the peasant at the end so um I love the
concept of Mabel conquering your fears
by remaking it yeah and into the Care
Bears character uh what did she what was
that character's name I forget it was
like a balloon can it sparkle star but
the message was always just believe in
yourself
Oh like that was always the message I
believe too much Oh hmm I love how they
talked about how expensive it is so they
just show it shadow the big epic fight
oh my god that was definitely the best
part that actually reminds me a lot they
had a video game version of the show
which is very much in the sound like the
Simpsons arcade a ninja turtles arcade
and it's amazing until you get to about
level three and you realize they're just
repeating the same foes to fire there's
no variety but then we get to the last
level they actually say it it's like you
know all you deal with row like you know
the same character says over and over
and say what did you expect on a limited
budget it's like okay now it now it's
alright is very it's like they
acknowledge it and they have fun to it
well I'm just the send up to Ray
Harryhausen like cuz Ray Harryhausen's
one of my heroes
so it just the fact that they went all
out made a kind of Ray Harryhausen did
some of his characters and then that
hilarious bed were like reading about
how like other effects have taken over
in the stop-motion characters themselves
the heart the heart my favorite is that
look so real and it's like just one of
the early versions of CG that just looks
steady and all looks like food fight or
something yeah so and that is still it's
that's still the argument about you know
CG against and drawn and so which which
is great that this show I mean which is
still hand-drawn I mean it's they're
still hand-drawn shows out there but
it's like my favorite kitchen ah oh per
uh older films time for references we
won't understand and language we can't
repeat yeah
it's true whatever I like look at some
of the like stuff that we grew up with
them like yeah things strangely you know
I don't know yeah they're definitely uh
like everybody already yeah everything
with kids shows nowadays is more
innuendo which it's not bad cuz you have
to be smarter but at the same time the
80s it's like yeah they said a lot of
stuff that's like we get a much heart a
much harsher rating now um they weren't
all Monster Squad that they were close
uh I was living the Christmas story when
Ralphie's just like a stupid commercial
son of a bitch he says it letters of
purpose bitch yeah I really like to be a
so much more funnier than five yeah um
but uh yeah I mean a good episode I love
the ending with the cheapskate uh you
know it's a good it's a principal in my
favor like the moral is story we've all
been saying why we love him just like
that's right I'm a jerk
why love at the end the hand was just as
he's walk away he's like I haven't
learned a thing
the one Joe gave felt they missed out on
that felt would have been funny is that
you know the hand which has the pickup
lines and this super chiseled guy comes
as excuse me I'm looking for a place to
you know hang out and just rest while I
you know from climbing and she opens up
the pickup line that says girl you look
so hot in those pants he's like oh
thanks for noticing and like it seems to
work I thought it would been funnier if
he said thanks for noticing and for
acknowledging I'm a girl so few people
realize that she goes now or maybe even
fire gym like yes just play like the
expectations so on the gay jokes it's
it's funny not that there's anything
wrong with it you just would have
guessed it and if she said yes at the
end as well it'd be like all cool they
are legit so there's nothing wrong with
that whatsoever
what's your problem with the gay jokes I
have a laundry basket on my head I'm not
judging anybody oh oh by the way small
chillers
uh so we get this one three sweaters not
the box one was one chocolate bar was
the last one the middle one was a rock
guitar uh for when she was doing what
was it Mabel in the hoggar with AM show
yeah
the foot slam the first one believed was
a heart diamond I think if I remember
correct I think I was making even
crazier than the sweat Oh sweetie I just
wear a laundry basket for the recipes
maybe maybe oh man now I gotta readjust
there we go
anywho uh basic episode but still funny
he's still a lot of fun oh I think the
stop-motion one especially was like just
really great eventually did the
stop-motion and I feel like dark helmet
Gabriel I study your Schwartz is this
big as mine you think that's a band they
get the white helmet hope I dyed it as
upside ensign it's two sides every short
yeah he sees the bright side to the
shorts oh there you go
or no no one had long everyone been
always looking the desert becoming the
desert we found which I wrote our
first saw that when the force awakens
trailer came out like I saw that buzz
I'm like oh my god that's hilarious
nobody else will ever think of it like
it's all over here now like everyone's
posted bantha we a fashion thing so but
you tried yeah well I I didn't post I
just saw it I'm like wow I'm gonna share
this like I shouldn't nobody else it's
not that it's like 20 different versions
of that same name so um yeah good stuff
and we will see you next episode
maybe with laundry basket Lonestar ow
bye